Шановні колеги очевидно що ми знаємо всі
Павла рябікіна як досвідченого менеджера
з великою історією але мова зараз навіть
не про нього бо ми добре знаємо про
Павла рябікіна що ми знаємо про
українську промисловість що ми знаємо
про українську військову промисловість
Подивіться на ті країни які воюють
Подивіться на ті країни які нам
допомагають вони роблять виробляють
зброю якою всі пишаються ця зброя
поступає до нас вони збільшують
виробництво очевидно Ми теж пишаємося
українською зброєю саме з української
зброї виготовленої до 19-го року було
знищено крейсер Москва саме українська
зброя стугне вироблені до 19-го року
зараз знищують російські танки і цієї
української зброї було би набагато
більше якби ми перед самою війною не
гальмували штучну оборонне замовлення
нашим підприємствам але це минуле Що
відбувається зараз нічого
створено було Міністерство чи ефективно
працювало цей Міністерство є штучний Ну
не конфлікт а не відповідний розподіл
обов'язків між міністерством і
укроборонпромом хто за що відповідає
безліч чиновників але оборонпром і це
Міністерство і зброя не працюють і зброя
не виробляється в чому причина так ми
можемо сказати що зараз ми живемо в
небезпечний час оскільки нібито е-е
наші підприємства можуть постраждати від
бомбардувань ворога-агресора справді
можуть постраждати але немає жодної
воюючої країни яка не може собі
дозволити не виробляти зброю бо наша
зброя не буде мати жодних обмежень ні
для накриття російською Федерації ні для
накриття будь-яких інших агресорів які
будуть атакувати Україну
націоналізували підприємство КрАЗ
віддали державі що сталося стоїть
підприємство звільнили на людей його
закрили це робота держави тому
врешті-решт Укроборонпром ми маємо
колись нормально запустити дякую